good afternoon everyone my name is
Kirsty Sinclair Doutzen I'm a graduate
student here at Yale in the history of
our film and Media Studies program and
before I introduce the film I really did
want to say thank you so much to
everyone who's been involved in this
conference particularly Sofie Tatyana
Eric Tim for putting this together but
also all of the other speakers and
particularly thank you to David for your
wonderful keynote which is quite a hard
act to follow I have to say and as I've
said to a few of you over this weekend
I'm a strong believer that the first
time you see a film you should come
through it without any preconceptions
and that no prior critical
interpretation should affect your
initial responses to it a position
that's somewhat compromised by having to
introduce the film to you I thought it
would be interesting just to have a show
of hands how many of you have seen the
film before okay not many so for those
of you who haven't don't worry I'm not
gonna spoil anything hopefully but what
I thought I'd do instead of maybe
speaking too much about the production
history of the film or the plot which is
something we can do in the roundtable
afterwards I'm gonna try and reconstruct
how British audiences would have first
encountered this film in the autumn of
1944 and in the roundtable afters were
definitely going to talk a little bit
about how American audiences would have
encountered this when it was
subsequently released there in 1949 in a
slightly different version and I really
hoping we're gonna play a clip from that
murderd version because I think you'll
get a real kick out of it
I think it's far too easy now and we
watch films digitally projected on DVD
in a nicely lit lecture hall in
competition with lots of other screens
in the room to try and reconstruct what
it would have been like to see this film
originally so I'm just gonna ask you all
for a minute to imagine along with me
that we're going to the cinema in the
autumn of 1944 and this probably means
that we're
mostly young working-class northern
women if you can imagine it the people
that predominantly made up cinema
audiences in Britain at this time
perhaps you've been relocated away from
home in order to contribute to the war
effort and you've decided to visit one
of nearly 5,000 cinemas in operation in
Britain at this time perhaps you ride
the bus into town where a female
conductor takes your ticket just as the
woman staffing the box office will when
you arrive at the cinema as film
exhibition was almost entirely run by
women during World War two
as you enter the theater you pass from
one dark space into another from the
blacked-out City into the black box of
the cinema where both exist as spaces in
which all kinds of things can happen
away from the watchful eyes of parents
police and partners and of course the
theaters crowded as film audiences
swelled to unprecedented levels during
the war with high levels of unemployment
and little else to spend one's income on
so you find a seat at the back of the
theater near the projection booth a
dangerous place to sit in the days of
nitrate film stock and for those of you
that don't know nitrate is so flammable
it not only Auto ignites but once it's
ablaze it's actually almost impossible
to extinguish even when fully submerged
in water so beware so maybe you've
missed the newsreel and the B picture
and you've arrived almost halfway
through a Canterbury tale as we're still
well over a decade away from appointment
to view cinema where audiences would
arrive at the start of the film and
leave at the end but then perhaps you've
seen this film before wartime shortages
meant that Britain produced fewer than
50 films a year at this time while
audience numbers tripled so you look out
across a row of bobbing heads the
projector beam illuminated by the rising
smoke from carefully rationed cigarettes
and what do you see on the screen well
you see an image of
has a projector beam illuminated by
rising smoke from carefully rationed
cigarettes while this sequence which
occurs about an hour into your
Canterbury tale depicts not a movie
theater but a lantern slide lecture it's
hard not to think of this as a scene
that reflects the cinematic audience
back at themselves and while British
cinema during World War two is often
praised for its realism as documentary
filmmakers started working in commercial
studios
it seems that rather than films becoming
more like life life was increasingly
becoming more like cinema going so this
world smoke and charas Goro and
ascribing may in fact sound more like
the most iconic of American wartime
genres the film noir than a true Syrian
homefront film by Powell and Pressburger
but I think it's important to consider
the many noir elements that run
throughout the film not least as a way
of noting the craftsmanship of the
German production designer alfred
younger and cinematographer oh and
hillier but also as a way of thinking
about whether the British and American
film industries were truly in the same
boat at this time certainly both
Hollywood and the British film industry
shared some of the same limitations
during the war lack of person now as
technical staff and stars were called up
for service a lack of resources
particularly in Britain as a lot of the
studios were commandeered by the
military for storage space or as shadow
factories but also increased censorship
as both governments realize the power of
cinema to propagandize and also subvert
however one key difference which
separated Hollywood from Britain and one
that I think's best illuminated by
considering the noir elements of a
Canterbury tale is their anticipation of
the post-war landscape of their
respective industries of course
hollywood's turns of film noir was in
part due to the influx of German
immigrants relocating there during the
war but perhaps was more to do with the
paranoia felt in the Indus
three over the pending antitrust case
against the studios which had been
temporarily put on hold during the
conflict the Hollywood studio system was
well aware at the close of the war as
the close of the war approached that
it's days were numbered as governmental
clamp downs on their cartel practices
mostly block booking and blind selling
film so the exhibitors actually had very
little say over what they screened meant
that the heyday would soon be over
the British Studios on the other hand
had really never had it so good
far from trying to hamper the British
film industry the government had for
some time been trying to kick-start it
in order to rival the market dominance
of Hollywood and the Second World War
was the moment when they finally
succeeded as it became the first and
possibly only time when British motion
pictures outperformed American movies at
the box office and this is particularly
surprising given the fact that Hollywood
was more aggressively exporting its
films to Britain than before the war
eager to get a foothold in a market
where domestic production was
anticipated to be on the verge of
collapse now I think British cinema
during World War Two is often written
about as though the only filmmakers
working in Britain with the
documentarians at the crowne film unit
but I just want to remind you that there
were three commercial studios Ealing
Gainsborough and Alexander quarters
London films still operational during
the war and when we think about British
cinema in this period we can't just
discuss let me listen to Britain
Humphrey Jennings work fires were
started but we should also be thinking
about Gainsborough melodramas like the
man in grey and technical of spectacles
like the Thief of Bagdad and Henry v
which are all enormous hits at the box
office during this period so while we
might find in a Canterbury tale a
melancholy reminiscent of American film
noir perhaps it's due to the buoyancy of
the British film industry that paranoia
and nihilism have here been replaced
with optimism and cynicism has been
replaced with a mystic belief in
miracles and I don't think there's a lot
more I can say without ruining your
one tainted experience of the film but
I'll just leave you with a quote from
Pressburger when he introduced the film
himself at MoMA in 1980 where he
described his films as a nest in which
magic can settle I really look forward
to discussing the film with you all
after the screening